TAKAKO AIKAWA: So we had
two different sessions.
One is grammar session, and
the other one is drill session.
Grammar session is to teach or
introduce new grammar items,
and usually, we do
this grammar session,
we are using English, especially
for beginners classes.
The drill session is to practice
what students have learned
in grammar session,
so lots of drills
and interactive activities
in class, and drills sessions
are entirely in Japanese, even
from day two of the first year.
And in terms of
proportion, we usually
spend one day for
grammar session
and four to five days for
drill sessions per each lesson.
So for grammar
session, the students
are supposed to read grammar
notes of the textbook, so
each lesson, we have grammar
notes on the textbook.
And at the same
time, each lesson
introduces 40 to 50
new vocabularies,
so students are supposed to
learn those new vocabularies as
well.
For drill sessions,
we have a lot
of online interactive
exercises, so students
are supposed to go
to this online site
and then do a lot of practice.
So conducting drills
sessions entirely in Japanese
it's quite challenging
for us, but I
believe that language needs
to be learned together
with context.
So as a language
teacher, and then
I believe that other
colleagues do the same thing,
too, we bring a
lot of visual aids.
so that the classroom becomes
more like a real context,
and then we try to create
a so-called immersive
environment in
class, and that way
we can conduct
interactive drills.